ich habe es zwar nicht gefragt aber
Alexi beexi erklärt es trotzdem warum
keine Zahnpasta mit diesem
zahnweißgranuladsteinchen benutzen das
im Fragenlotto und es geht darum warum
benutzt er Autotune und um sein
Perfektionismus und natürlich um noch
viel mehr also haut rein und schaut
rein so also liebe Leute nicht irritiert
sein wir sind am Hamburger Hafen mit dem
fragen Leute mit Alexi bexi wenn hier ab
und zu mal der Wind in mein Mikro
reinbläst er hat einen tollen Puschel
aber mit so viel Wind mein Gott ihr habt
ja eine Menge Wind hier wie viel Wind
gibt's hier so er hat blasen und Buschel
gesagt oh hier gibt's immer viel gesagt
weiß ich nicht hier gibt's viel Wind ja
das stimmt schon v wir haben uns so eine
schöne Ecke ausgesucht wo es auch gerade
es ist wirklich eine Ecke von der Ecke
deswegen pustet es hier wirklich ganz
gut aber das muss man abkönnen das raue
Hamburger Wetter und das ist ja nicht
nur heute so wenn man im Norden lebt
aber deine Frisur sitzt ja Stein auf dem
Kopf kommen wir zum fragenl
ja fragen die roten sind gemeine Fragen
du kannst selber wählen du kannst so
viel ziehen wie du möchtest du kannst
und so weiter acho jetzt einmal rein und
gleich viele rausnehmen oder so nach wie
du möchtest du bist total frei se
kreativ vielleicht stckst du dir eine in
die Nase
und ne fangen wir doch mal mit einer
grünen an
genau wer muss das eigentlich immer
knicken und
tackern sehr oft mache ich
es schön wie schaffst du es so
professionell rüberzukommen tue ich das
findest du ja ja ich ist allein schon
deine Stimme ja da haben wir es doch es
liegt an der Stimme nein es ist noch
mehr das ist eine gute Frage das wir
eine gute Frage es ist bestimmt unter
anderem die die Stimme aber
vielleicht das Stichwort vielleicht
gehört dazu noch
einfach gefasst zu sein also im
entscheidenden Moment einfach das albern
wegzulassen und einfach mal zu sagen so
jetzt Rei ich mich zusammen bleib auf
dem
und alles wird gut ich glaube das macht
schon viel aus bei solchen Geschichten
werde ich jetzt verklagt weil h Müll
rumfliegt
ja
warum warum bist du so sexistisch ja
Christop sag doch mal warum bist du ich
bin ja nicht so sexistisch es ist witzig
ich hö öfters oder lese öfters diesen
Kommentar unter speziell natürlich unter
erklär unter dem Erklärbär komisch
eigentlich ja ganz merkwürdig verstehe
ich gar nicht
aber das Thema se ist unserer heutigen
Jugend gehört dazu so doof das klingt
und wenn man es nicht als Tabuthema
betrachtet sondern man nebenbei auchus
seine Späßen dazu macht finde ich
zumindest ist das weiß nicht das ist
heutzutage kann man damit lockerer
umgehen und viele so wie es ja scheint
sehen das ganze dann gleich als
sexistisch oder Sexismus an wenn man mal
mit mit ein schlüpfriigen Spruch oder
sowas rüberkommen was ja im Fernsehen
oder im Radio eigentlich jeden taggang
und Gebe ist man muss einfach nur
morgens mal eine morningsh auf dem
Radiosender einschalten und da wirst
wirst du zugeballert mit sowas mal als
Beispiel m hier ist es so ich mache mir
einfach nur Spaß aus Dingen die man so
aus dem Alltag schon kennt an Sprüchen
und so weiter
und gehe natürlich durch das Thema was
ja sonst Tabu ist auch mit mit mit
Dildos und so weiter ein bisschen in
extreme rein das ist aber trotzdem so
wie es ja heutzutage ist in unserer
Gesellschaft locker und spaßig
aufgenommen werden kann ohne dass sich
jemand so hoffe ich es zumindest in
irgendeiner Art und Weise angegriffen
fühlt und so weiter aber oder ich denke
dass es heute machbar ist sich auch mal
ein Späße mit dem Dildo zu machen und
ich mache es ja nicht nur seit dem
erklärb sondern es war auch schon vorher
in anderen Videos
drin mal so als kleiner
Seitenhieb ich sehe das
locker wusstest du bei einer Zahnpasta
wo diese weisheitsmacher drin sind diese
kleinen Kristalle dass man sich seine
Zähne kaputt schrubt nein und das
Zahnfleisch zurückgeht ja man soll auf
jeden Fall wieder die klassische
Zahnpasta nehmen wo nicht diese kleinen
Granit Dinger drin sind Granulat Dinger
drin sind damit man länger was von
seinen Zehnen hat ist interessant ja
weil sonst raut man die auf und die
werden gelb vom Kaffee oder Verbrauch
oder dann brauchen wir noch mehr von
dieser Zahnpasta die macht dann quasi ja
entweder die Klassiker die halt nicht
sowas drin haben oder so eine Zahn
Pasten pastas Pasten Pasten die
spezielles Aufbaumittel drin haben damit
man sein seine Zähne wieder stärbt
wollte ich am Anfang auch nicht glauben
aber nachdem ich irgendwie einige
Zahnärzte besucht habe ist ist
tatsächlich Fakt so nächste Frage was
macht dich so
einzigartig weil ich vielleicht nicht so
rede wie manch anderer liegt's doch an
der Stimme liegt's an meiner Frisur oder
an der Brille vielleicht würde ich ohne
Brille auch nur wie ein ganz normaler
Mensch aussehen
was macht mich einzigartig ich glaube
gegenüber vielen anderen dass ich es
weiterhin auch schaffe auf dem Boden zu
bleiben und das fehlt bei vielen es ist
also ich finde gerade das immer wieder
sich selbst von außen möglichst kritisch
zu beurteilen also auf höchstem Niveau
gar gar perfektionistisch zu sein finde
ich es extrem wichtig weil extrem
anstrengend ja da sind wir auch wieder
bei dem Thema Traum wenn man durch
Albträume geht wie am
Anfang wenn man das nicht macht verliert
man den Blick auf sich selbst und auf
seine Umgebung und dann landet man wo
viele andere landen in überzogenheit
Arroganz
Überheblichkeit Ignoranz auch in
vielerlei
Hinsicht
und ich glaube das ist das was mich in
gewisser Art und Weise noch einzigartig
macht weil ich kenne auch viele wo es
nicht so
ist okay noch eine rude oh ja rote gut
ich guck mal kurz auf die Uhr ja guck
mal auf die Uhr oh alles klar noch eine
rote na gut ser
gut das ist so lang war schon mal König
der Löwen hier eigentlich ja äh ja ja
ich hab ja ja weil ich habe leider nur
den letzten Akt gesehen oh ist schade
weil ich konnte ich hatte ja okay obwohl
mir da war immer wieder beim stressigen
ja hast du keine eigenen Ideen oder
warum übersetzt du fremde Songs auch
eine Sache die man immer wieder hört
ganz
klar was aber nicht ganz stimmt weil wer
genau guckt es gibt ja auch eigene Songs
von
daher ich habe schon eigene Ideen so ist
das nicht aber es ist ja gerade der Reiz
zu zeigen was international so oder
weltweit durch die Gegend kursiert und
was mindestens acht Mal in der Stunde
oder 20 Mal in der schulhofpause auf dem
Handy läuft
deswegen sind es gerade diese deutschen
Songs geworden um zu gucken was wird
dort gesungen teilweise was für ein
Quatsch und was für manchmal doch ganz
nette Sachen manchmal auch viel Quatsch
ja ja gut noch eine rote oder grün zum
Schluss du kannst dich entscheiden hab
wir nur eine rote komm gut was wäre denn
Youtube ohne Hater das hatten wir schon
nicht
Youtube ja was wäre das Leben ohne Hater
nein Privatleben hat man schon wenig
Hater oder weiß ich nicht die Sagen sind
jedenfalls nicht offen ne ja die Hater
sind glaube ich eher übers wenn dann
übers internetaktiv ich glaube nicht so
face to face absolut nicht außer in
Berlin ja Berlin du benutzt ständig
autotunen kannst du nicht
singen gut aufgepasst ja Autotune nutze
ich
aber ich würde sagen stellt euch mal vor
Nickelback würde einen Song von Maroon 5
Singen nickelbeck hat eine tiefe raue
Stimme Maroon 5 eher so den
eierquetscher ich glaube nicht dass er
das könnte vielleicht wenn er wirklich
ein ultra professioneller und geübter
Sänger ist kriegt das vielleicht hin
aber im Regelfall ist es schwierig ist
das wirklich so ein Problem fremde Songs
zu singen ja und genau das sind beim
Thema ich habe eine ich habe nicht
unbedingt die Singstimme das hört man
glaube ich es ist eher so der der der
Basston der vielleicht für köre oder
sowas gedacht wäre oder für Barry White
Musik oder Tom Jones Interpretation aber
für
Popsongs müsste man mir doch noch zwei
dreimal in die Diamanten treten damit
das funktionieren würde und als
Hilfsmittel gibt's natürlich Autotune um
das Ganze auch ordentlich hinzubiegen
was ich nicht schlimm finde ehrlich
gesagt weil 90% der Musik die ihr hört
ist mit autotunen verseucht einige
weniger offensichtlich die anderen mehr
offensichtlich
m und da beschwert sich natürlich keiner
warum weil dan neben to Q steht Punkt
so ich sehe das nicht so eng ich nutze
Autotune was in Ordnung ist aber was am
Ende bei rauskommt ist schön die ist bei
eigenen
Songs nein dann nicht nee weil die
eigenen Songs die ich bisher gemacht
habe sind ja schon so gewählt dass es
von der Stimmlage auch passt und da ist
es eigentlich nicht dabei nein aber KST
wahrscheinlich wahnsinnig viel Zeit ja
unfassbar doch also gerade bei dem bei
dem bei dem ersten Song also der
Valentinstag Song der romantische Song
der das war ja wirklich ein
100% mit der Hand und Akustikgitarre
eingespieltes Ding der zweite war ja
mehr synti mehr elektrisch das hat
wirklich viel Zeit in Anspruch genommen
also wenn die Zeit aber da ist wird es
wieder einen neuen geben ein weiteren
geben auf jeden Fall super bin gespannt
ich auch ich nicht mehr okay W schaff ja
vielen Dank ger hat mich sehr gefreut
und noch mehr Fragenlotto Videos gibt es
bei klicksum z.B das mit Matze Knop der
sagt ich bin mir für nichts zu schade
warum das so ist erfahrt ihr im Video
und warum i
geldgeil ist zumindest sagt er das das
erfaht er im Fragenlotto mit iBlali also
bis dann bleib
dran